valorent has entered its villain era
Evil Geniuses have silenced every
doubter and hater and are your world
champions and let's be honest you didn't
think it was gonna happen
[Music]
before we get into it if you watch this
weekend you might know I love the
perfect combination of Esports and a
good drink so our new show into the dark
brought to you by Kraken is the perfect
show for me and you it follows the
stories of the biggest Risk Takers in
Esports simple Imperial Hal and nade
shot and anyone else who took the path
Less Traveled and emerged Victorious
don't forget to check it out via the
link in the description below and make
yourself a nice night cap while you do
if you're of legal drinking age don't
get it twisted so I was at Champs as
some of you know and I was so excited
and shouting the whole time that I lost
my voice so I'm very sorry for sounding
like this but at least you know I had a
great time
have such a great time exactly
well
[Applause]
Story three world champions Evo geniuses
Evil Geniuses defeated paper wrecks
become the Valiant champions of 2023 and
have officially made North America the
reigning world Champs but in order to
understand why this is such a big deal
we not only have to go back to the
beginning of the regular season but the
preseason back in 2022 after Valor
announced their partner teams closely
known as franchise all of the teams were
making roster moves rumored and official
but EG was dead silent the joke of the
scene was not only wow nothing's being
done but also that EG had only 10 fans
but eventually we got news a 10-person
roster for our 10 kids
and they thought we didn't know we made
franchising so the main roster was going
to be Ethan com George Mo bustio and vcj
with five others on the reserve roster
their first top was the inaugural single
elimination tournament of lock-in where
they won once against team Heretics and
then lost to Talon but that was just the
beginning they still had the regular
season to go through that regular season
however
didn't start out all that great they
lost in pretty close games to Cloud 9
and when they met hundred thieves they
also lost the first map but before we
got to the second map of Hunter thieves
there was news fan favorite bcj was
being swapped out for demon one so demon
one would be playing on icebox the demon
is coming in
for bcj so demons
demon for bcj put this into perspective
bcj is a fantastic player and a good
friend of mine who was on exit before
this playing initiator and it was known
for being one of the best initiators in
the country some might even say the
world when on EG he was put onto smokes
a role he did not play not that he
played it badly it's just something he
didn't spend time playing sure on next
said he played some Omen when the team
needed it but he never really saw him on
the Astra or the brim so when the
decision was made to pull bcj from the
starting lineup and replace him with
demon 1 a duelist people were confused
and upset not only doubting the players
but doubting Potter had been coaching EG
since 2021 and to make matters worse EG
didn't really have a great season after
that including being 13-0 by loud so
to paint a picture for you people saw a
solution to a non-problem that didn't
work deep in one was performing well but
for such a dramatic change there wasn't
really a dramatically different result
and there was a bunch of talk about
Potter both people saying that she
needed to go and the people defending
her but the vitriol was intense EG had
even qualified for playoffs or Masters
Tokyo but not all hope was lost you see
that technically still could have
qualified if mibr
beat hundred thieves the team everyone
expected to win and mibr was playing
with an assistant coach as AFL so it's
not like they could have expected to
qualify
right your turn your turn wait wait they
don't know they don't know they don't
know
shoot the [__] God
[Music]
so EG qualifies for playoffs because
mibr's assistant coach got a knife kill
to win them the game to really get into
the nitty-gritty Egypt qualified with a
map differential over Sentinels and a
round differential over 100 thieves
that's confusing just know the math is
mathing that's all you need to know so
playoffs came where they do in fact
qualify for Tokyo but in this case DB1
was most likely going to be unable to
play in Tokyo due to Visa issues but
Hell hath no fury like the EG wanting a
title because somehow some way demon 1
gets a passport and his ass on a plane
to Tokyo in Tokyo they had a pretty
impressive run losing to fnatic in the
grand finals first off fnatic is widely
considered to be the best team in the
world at this point second off for a
team that didn't qualify for playoffs
that is an incredible result on paper
but when you're watching the games
you're seeing the calls you're seeing
the mechanics the team is getting better
and better by the day Moving On by
placing second at Masters Tokyo they
automatically qualify for Champions no
knife kills by another team's assistant
coach needed for Champions it was more
pressure than doubters we have seen what
EG could do but could they prove that
their success is more than just a flash
in the pan they played well making it
out of groups defeating food and fpx not
dropping a single map but then we get
into the playoffs EEG beats EDG 2-1
defeat drx2o and then meet people Rex in
the upper bracket final paper x complete
with a star duelist of their own named
something defeats EG and extremely tight
games two to one the kwabusio It Feels
So Impossible sometimes just to play
rounds against them honestly it's not
fun to play against them they are really
good but they are just so aggressive
there's a lot going on versus them and
it sucks but what you gonna do easy you
move to the lowers where they once again
have to face loud loud had just sent
fnatic home the most best team in the
world if EG lose here they are the ones
going home in a game that went the full
five Maps Evil Geniuses silenced loud
and made their way to the Grand finals
where paper Rex was waiting for them
paper racks coming from the upper
bracket had the map veto Advantage Evil
Geniuses are facing the team that had
just beat them in a pretty unfavorable
position games can be won or lost in the
pick bands alone so it's the grand
finals Evil Geniuses are playing in
front of an audience full of people that
probably doubted them and discarded them
only a few months earlier and they are
at a major disadvantage and while they
have everything to gain they have
everything to lose no one remembers
those in second place moments sure but
as those who raised the trophy above
their head that are etched in history
there are no anthologies of second
placeholders just winners if you are
Evil Geniuses did you come all this way
to get second again just start a trend
of being always the bridesmaid but never
the bride you came all this way and for
what to prove the doubters right no if
you're Evil Geniuses you came to take it
all and davara someone else's words if
that makes you the villain so [__] be it
as it turned out at validated Champions
there were no Heroes to stop our
villains EG defeat paper Rex only
dropping a single map in our your world
champions the team that everyone doubted
and I mean the individual players and
coaches they received so much hatred and
belittling and bullying they are the
ones in the end to raise the trophy
above their head I spent so long on
their journey in the regular season
because I want you to think about this
day after day week after week people
belittling them and bullying them saying
they should lose their job and much much
worse that is what they went through so
does AJ know they made franchising
yeah I would think so
I need I need to set the record straight
Danny and you set it straight
there are those out there who don't
believe I was sober and don't believe
those were genuine those were 100
genuine and I was dead so where those
margaritas were watery as hell
also like are we surprised I'm a
Italian-American from New Jersey who was
also a theater kid you think I'm just
gonna sit there with my hands on my lap
like are you kidding me